st. Mark's Square Venice Italy it's one
of the most visited tourist destinations
in the world most years in mid-march
it's crowded with people hanging out in
cafes checking out the cathedral and
writing gondolas but in March of 2020
st. Mark's Square was practically empty
more and more people in northern Italy
had tested positive for the highly
contagious corona virus to slow down the
spread of the virus
the Prime Minister told everyone to stay
home alone also del Italia in la nostra
my and they listened a big part of the
reason they could do that is because of
a national policy in Italy everyone
there is guaranteed paid sick days no
matter their job the same is true in the
UK and Germany and Spain and Japan and
Ireland and Austria and Australia and
Norway and France and well basically all
wealthy countries but in the u.s. a huge
number of workers face a very different
reality these restaurant workers in New
Orleans are demanding emergency sick pay
during the corona virus pandemic
unlike in all these countries there is
no national law in the u.s. guaranteeing
workers the right to paid sick days
instead whether you have that right
depends on where you live and who you
work for
it's a system that leaves tens of
millions of the lowest paid Americans
vulnerable and it's about to be tested
by the biggest global pandemic in a
hundred years
if you look at how other countries
handle paid sick leave some of them like
Italy in Japan
pay workers directly out of a social
security fund others like Germany New
Zealand and Australia have laws that
require employers to foot the bill in
Ireland and Spain it's a combination of
both but they all do it for the same
reason because it helps contain the
spread of disease and can save lives
when workers have to choose between
making money and staying home when
they're sick the incentive is for them
to come to work which can get their
customers and co-workers sick that's an
especially big problem during a pandemic
like coronavirus when hospitals might
already be at capacity which would mean
some people can't get medical attention
which would mean more people would die
that's why the website of the CDC
America's main public health agency is
unambiguous about what you should do if
you're sick right now stay home but if
staying home means not being able to pay
your rent it might not be that simple
I'm a production assistant I'm a music
educator I work in Houston Texas as
their stage head I am a line opener at a
bakery by day a bartender by night and
neither job offers paid sick days I
don't get sick days because I'm not
staff I'm hired like day to day I'm a
contract worker so that means we're
ineligible for benefits or paid sick
leave at all if for any reason I have to
call in sick the company caused an
expression on the list and I do not get
paid
it basically means I start playing
Tetris with my living expenses and pull
money away from one bill to squeeze it
into another so it makes things
complicated and a bit scary in recent
years service industry workers have
pushed for new paid sick leave laws in
cities and states across the country and
in a handful of places they've succeeded
but service workers are a huge part of
every state's economy so why haven't
they been more successful in getting
paid sick days in more places part of
the reason why starts here in Milwaukee
Wisconsin
in 2008 voters there passed a paid sick
leave referendum by a huge margin but
three years later the state's Republican
Governor Scott Walker signed a bill that
said no city in Wisconsin could require
employers to provide their employees
with leave of any kind
Milwaukee's new paid sick leave law was
toast then later that same year an
executive from the company Yum Brands
which owns KFC Taco Bell and Pizza Hut
went to a meeting of the American
Legislative Exchange Council or Alec
it's a group that rights legislation for
Republican state lawmakers all over the
country so they don't have to write it
themselves they handed out copies of
that Wisconsin bill in the decade sense
republican-controlled state legislatures
in 16 other states have passed nearly
identical laws including Louisiana home
of those New Orleans protestors but now
that there's a pandemic the u.s. really
needs sick workers everywhere to stay
home that's partly why on March 18th
2020 president Trump signed a
coronavirus relief bill that vice
president Mike Pence described to the
American people this way if you're sick
stay home you're not gonna miss a
paycheck the problem is that's not true
the Democrats original bill gave
everyone access to paid sick days but to
get Republicans on board they made some
concessions the bill
does contain a line that says an
employee shall be entitled to paid sick
time during public health emergencies
the problem is that rule only applies to
companies with between 50 and 500
employees and companies that size only
employ about 20% of American workers so
even with this new bill millions of
workers at big national chains like
McDonald's Walmart Kroger and Pizza Hut
still don't have paid sick days
there are lots of American workers that
do have paid sick leave many also have
the privilege of working from home
during the crisis but coronavirus
doesn't distinguish between people who
have that privilege and those who don't
that means that the status quo puts all
Americans at risk because we're only as
safe as our least protected neighbors
[Music]
you